what is going on everybody welcome to
part 20 of our matplotlib tutorial
series in this tutorial what we're gonna
be talking about is adding this kind of
subplot handling to our previous
tutorials so if you're following along
linearly revisit your code from part 18
otherwise I'll put a link in the
description that will send you to part
18 so you can get the starting code so
that starting code should look like this
ok so that's from tutorial number 18 I'm
just gonna highlight copy everything
come over here control a control v don't
now what we're gonna go ahead and do is
change our axes here so right now we are
doing a subplot to grid we just aren't
doing the one we want which is actually
going to be a six by one and let's go
ahead and take all this copy paste paste
actually let's before we do that let's
let's do so this will be zero zero and
then what we want to go ahead and do is
we're going to say
rowspan equals 1 and then colspan
colspan also equals 1 and then take this
copy now paste paste this start point
will be whoops not 1 and then this start
point will be 5 and then what we'll do
this will be a 4 and then everything
else stays the same right so now this is
access to this is actually 3 so now
where we want to plot price is actually
going to be on axes 2 so we're gonna
come down here to where we are plotting
this candlestick and we plot it to axes
to subsequently all this other stuff
needs to be kind of fixed however really
we've got a lot of stuff we're gonna
have to change here but for now we'll
just we'll change this to axes 2 and
then all this stuff will also be axes 2
2 2 2
good enough let's render that see what
we're looking at cool so immediately you
should see there's quite a few issues
the first notable issues that the the
chart title is happening down at the at
the bottom here we're gonna fix that our
gates are really not showing up very
well we've got price over here we need
that to be up here and date really
should apply to this but it's applying
down here so so we've got a little bit
of a mess that's the whole point of
carrying on in this tutorial however so
closing out of all this the first thing
that we want to go ahead and do is let's
come down to ax two here good the next
thing that I want us to go ahead and do
is let's come to see ax 3 let's go down
to where we're identifying these titles
in the labels and all of that and what
we're gonna first do is we're gonna take
the label for X&Y
and really the title that kind of needs
to be changed too so really the title
needs to be defined will actually get
rid of the title for now I think and
we'll come back to the title part but
for X&Y label what we're gonna go ahead
and do basically what happens is as
you're plotting
axes when it comes time to give labels
you have to give the labels at the time
of whatever you're editing so the last
thing that we're really adding here is
ax 3 so when we add a title for example
that's being added to ax 3 when really
we want the X label in the while able to
apply some control X there cut that we
want that to apply to ax 2 like that
also so if we want the title to be above
ax 1 what we'll do is we'll take the
title here cut there and put that up on
ax 1 like this okay
so now let me let's go ahead and let's
run that really quick and so now yeah
we've got title up at the top prices
down here date is theoretically down
here but what's happening is
is the date is so big that we're seeing
the AXYZ 3 is kind of covering over our
date here and it's causing that that's
the trouble were we're having there but
otherwise everything else looks like
it's being added as we would expect now
the other thing that we might want to do
is we need to add maybe some data to
these top and bottom charts and then
once we add data there we'll worry about
fixing the formatting of basically all
this other stuff so really just wanted
to move everything kind of where we want
to at least start with on this next
tutorial so I think what we'll do is
we'll stop it here and then we'll carry
on in the next tutorial with the rest of
the situation fixing what we want to do
so any problems up to this point your
graph should look like this a little
dilapidated but price should be down
here you should have your label over
here your title at the top and date and
stuff should be applying here but it's
kind of hard to tell but if date is
acting like it's a part of a x2 then
you're probably doing well so anyways if
you're having trouble getting it to at
least this point let me know otherwise
stay tuned the next video and thanks for
watching